no stars episode blue pulasky PS leave
Oscar Adame episode more programming
over Nia eagle
yeah - Moo Duk with the Wachowski at the
PTR the episode e on lash yet Duma
freezer doors open and get away Posada
pressure no sir - keep it shut it
bolivian style paranormal it actually up
the epidermis layer Kobe ple plu minuto
at the vape it soda bleep Oh skipper
stuck to the Nagas was dumb Poudre
Valley show Yahoo's keep schmear [ __ ]
[ __ ] waves of the coil touch to
ameerpet emotions - post doc posted Lea
leather walls fear GLA OPA we we have a
Minu - a trapeze of the Polsky texture
nice large ladies if we spend nights at
the Bissell touch Beatie like 'i know so
let me show you my was glad so - tada
B&E - whompin I said at the odd east oh
yeah it was tag delicious training to do
go in his small twin why push dagger if
there's a there's numerous company shot
on 1989 1989 TechNet EP beastie um at
the Nile Scriptures attorney in Slovakia
passbook tax type nikto big Tony
Smollett was not regulated I'll commit
away issue my penis was go sleepy video
demo no anyway okay
yes Clell unlisted slowly an email yeah
yeah yeah yeah I'm sure gotta cut a
couple skis kdg meter statically
post-editing me a boost a nice night and
bliss king of CL no macaque boy ma boy
ma boy who I am pretty mighty good boom
porchetta store Yahoo ski i bangla skip
item oh yeah i know like of nbc's lava
pacaya volcano option da at the Boyd
Canyon set over at the voice coach a
satanic tour de pinna might show a
gorgeous coming home with us - tada
Nagesh from Pinellas eat the WIPO
doesn't Sodom hey wassup guys my name is
a chino and that was yeah that was
totally in russian that first like
mineral sir of this episode this is
episode 50 so I thought I'd do something
special but yeah I hope you enjoyed that
little little Russian at the beginning
of that episode of this episode so yeah
today we're gonna take a look at
animating our player so what we go right
now is if you take a look
got their static sort of animation
doesn't really doesn't really cycle
through the different frames and if we
actually look at our our image of King
Cherno provided by a an Ewok Andy wall
of course you can see that we've got
sort of like three phases of animation
II and basically today what we're going
to do is want to take a look at cycling
through them so the first thing we need
to do if we come into our sprite class
over here of course there are several
ways of doing this I'm not gonna I'm
just gonna cut to the chase cut to the
chase not do any like really like
experiments or anything I'm not gonna
experiment with different uh different
ways of doing this I'm just gonna get
straight to the point and show you guys
the easiest way of doing it and then
maybe in the future I might mix it up if
you guys want me to in like a an
advanced section I guess in this series
so it's something like that but um yes
first thing when you do is actually I
guess import um our players so let's
just make a new sprite so I'm in a spy
class here so public static sprite and
we'll call it player well we'll just
call it player player player forward and
then we're just going to score one and
that'll be like that'll be this one so
the one that's under the original this
one so that equals new sprite course the
size is still 32 X is still zero but
instead of the play forward being um oh
wow we've got the name wrong that should
be bad so we'll just make it work like
capitals just so it doesn't know Oh
didn't work for factoring hang on let me
just save this back one protocol before
me to do sente okay I'll seem textures
are also is another factor alright so
let's call back with a capital B just
for now because we can't rename it to
something it's already taken so pull
that forward and then pull that back
with the locus B I'm just pressing alt
shift are we can also go to right-click
rough-ass or Iraq right click refactor
and then rename C old shifter and that
will just rename it everywhere for you
so um so yeah whoops got this little bar
up here not true idea really anyway so
play forward
will contain will basically be the same
as this play forward so 32 zero is
except instead of five it'll be one
lower says the y-coordinate it'll be
sixth and of course it will be it's
going to dark in here but it turn my
backlit Razer BlackWidow Ultimate it
turn that back light on so I can see
what I'm typing because I like to see
what I'm typing and play it forward to
write and then play forward to or just
be even law okay sway so let's just
let's just use that and it's actually
spreadsheets or files let's just use
that and see if that works first before
we move any further so let's go back
into our player class and all I'm going
to do an update is I'm going to make
basically a variable that just counts up
for us so let's just make private int
and a Malta's called an ml to stand for
animate and we'll make a zero to begin
with and basically every tick every CPU
cycle every time it actually runs update
method which is in every super it isn't
actually every CPU so I got like 60
times a second we'll just add one to
Anam and um just for safeguarding
because if someone does run the game for
like keeps it on for like over overnight
or something this can lead to a crash
since the integer variable can only
carry so many numbers just to safeguard
it would you just say that if an 'm is
actually less than let's just say like
we don't we honestly don't need it to
count let's just say past 7,500 i don't
know it's meant at all if it's less than
7,500 week we counted up else we'll just
set it equal to 0 all right makes sense
so in other words if our if the an
invariable is actually greater than
7,500 then we'll set it back to 0 and
start counting counting up again ok cool
that will just make sure that it doesn't
go to like a quadrillion being like a
quadrillion big if so actually just
leaves a game open yeah you always could
always think ahead so one other thing
that we need to do right here in terms
of variables is actually make a variable
for if were walking or not so bullying
walking
it was false to begin with so in other
words if we're pressing a key we're
walking so walking is a kinetic or true
here and if we're not are pressing a key
then walking is unequalled false okay
cool
swear glad we're glad we got that out of
the way so now let's take a look at this
thing so what we're going to do over
here is basically basically I love
saying that white of course best then
essentially for the one basically never
do again if if atom is equal to a
particular like factor so in other words
if an ax MS like every odd number that
atom is equal to half the time for
example then let's let's use one of the
animations all right it's a bit of a bit
of a bit of a stretch but um we'll take
a look at how that works so so if
walking and remember we want to do this
after sprite is already being assigned
because it's doing a chronological order
so there's no point in signing us right
there and then reassigning it to fourth
or something to work so if walking is
actually equal to true we also not only
just walking up to equal tour a bit also
and ah not really are we going to do
sprite flips here I'm not sure let's
let's do it this way listen through in
walking and then we'll do it another if
Sam in here if if an M let's just say
it's the remainder of let's just say 20
equals zero we can do something like
that that that'll know we want it to be
even so maybe greater than ten and I'll
explains in a minute
then we can make sprite equals bright
dot player forward one you know else
we'll make it play for two all right so
let's take a look at that see if that
works all right sweet look at that
awesome so that's how that works we
didn't really need to do that we could
have just done sprite flipping I might
do that next episode so like tomorrow
I'll show you guys how sprite flipping
sort of works because we obviously
didn't need to do this since it's
literally just flipping it but yeah
that's how that works so that's some
let's finish up the rest of the sprites
and and we'll call it a night I'll call
it a night it's getting late it's like
10:00 to 9:00 my sleep schedule is
actually back on track I'm going about
it like 10:00 to 11:00 p.m. and waking
up at like at 8 a.m. or so quarter to
eight because um because I got some big
projects to work on that I'm actually um
basically about a nine-to-five job to be
on full-time so that's um that's been
going on with me so yeah it is actually
getting land I mean that with the utmost
sincerity let's let's hop back into
sprite and we just need to do the rest
really all we will have to do flippin
won't we because of no no we won't
actually because I middle work the same
way does here but I'll still show you
guys how to do flipping in the future so
we can make obsolete some of these
things so side and then there's back so
back so of course if we open our sprite
sheet back up we can see the side is
just below the side I guess and then the
back side the back no that's the back
the back is just below the the original
back sprite so if we look at the
original back sprite we can see that
that's a 2 comma 5 so which means that
these will be at 2 comma 6 and 2 comma 7
and that player side that was originally
at 1 X so that would be 1 comma 6 and 1
comma 7 just like that so let's hop back
into our player and you can actually
play around with these numbers I'll
actually explain them in a minute after
culture but um let's copy all that this
is like the simplest possible way of
doing this I don't think there is a
simple way let's copy all that and we'll
pop it over here so if Direction is
equal to 1
so we'll make player so one means that
we're going left so player side one and
side two and we'll actually copy that
because we've got two sides to our
player a dark side and a bright side but
no we do up two sides because of course
we've got this flip yeah so there you go
and then the back one does it for this
one it's where we're going down Mayday
Mayday we going down but seriously we
are going down um does that work out
well no something's wrong something's
wrong with our syntax did I miss a that
really miss uh I think so
no it uh looks pretty legit huh
looks like we aren't missing them
maybe we've got no no we have to be Wow
definitely missing something what are we
missing
oh I'm missing a circular bracket know
what I don't know what you call but it
seems like we are missing a cycle a
bracket oh well let's just sort out the
syntax so what's the problem here we've
got that I got the else bracket oh here
we go
- better okay sweet so um we'll change
this to play out back and play it back
okay so let's check let's take a look at
that that works that does not work that
doesn't work and that is yeah this is
hilarious alright so we obviously
nestling up there um of course three
should be side my bad what about done
what about in that should be there and
that should be there take a look now so
that's side that still doesn't really
work properly that is my property side
to side there's a problem with side but
that's internal of house head Bob sup
Bob's up and down that's adorable
okay so and you can see if we start
walking the animation
doesn't actually stop and the reason it
doesn't stop us because we've forgotten
this if walking thing that we used to
care so much about so I'm let's pump
that back in my flip should be outside
of there I'm worried I'm actually kind
of wondering okay good that stops I'm
actually going to wondering why the flip
isn't working here because it should be
the sprite should just get flipped
maybe tell me was wrong with planar
because there's obviously a problem
because it's not working here either it
looks like oh no that's just the
animation that's actually what the
animation looks like it's look too good
all right Andy wall get on a fixed my
damn animation bro that looks very
broken but yeah other than that guys
that is episode 50 of game program we
hope you enjoyed it that is how you
animate your thing I almost forgot to
explain this part actually so this is
the way that this works animation right
it's a number and it's growing in size
all the time
daily not daily every um 60 times a
second is increasing right so it's going
up by 60 every second
Elvis it should be and then basically
what we're saying here is that whenever
it's like whenever if you divided by 20
oh sorry if you divide it by a number
and you get the remainder of 20 so in
other words that means every 20 like
multiples of this number whenever
whenever Adam is a multiple of 20 and
whenever that remainder is like greater
than 10 so in other words every it's
almost like half the time really then
we'll change the sprite if if it's that
and in half the time when it isn't that
will make the sprite that okay and then
this this is here just to safeguard in
case something goes wrong and that's how
all these bright works so I hope you
guys understood that it's quite a long
episode but yeah hope you enjoy this
episode again programming nd wall if
you're watching this get back on fixing
my sprite I expect an email ASAP bro
um I'm just getting I sound like a
really main person tonight you know I'm
joking right I'm just having a bit of
fun with us anyway I hope you guys
enjoyed this episode together I mean we
did please hit that like button I'll see
you guys tomorrow with the brand-new
episode glad guys
you